[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
people are being urged to prepare for
floods over the coming months as the uk
is predicted to be in line for more
rainfall than usual this winter
according to the met office there is an
above average chance of wetter
conditions with flooding most likely in
january and february next year the
environment agency has urged people to
check their flood risk online and sign
up for flood warnings
if carbon emissions continue to rise at
the current rate the uk will see far
more flooding the ipcc predicts that by
2050 sea levels will rise by 15 to 25
centimeters leading to coastal flooding
you can see the areas that will be
hardest hit here they include portsmouth
on the south coast kensington and
chelsea in london and east riding in
northern england
and as rainfall is predicted to increase
homes on floodplains are also at higher
risk of flooding that puts a total of
5.2 million properties in the uk at risk
of flooding
by 2080 flash floods caused by extreme
rainfall are expected to increase
five-fold
cities will be hit the most by this type
of surface water flooding because they
have a lot of hard surfaces like paved
front gardens roads and car parks that
prevent rainfall from being absorbed
well joining me now is professor lizzie
kendon climate scientist at the met
office hello to you at lizzie let's talk
first about the immediate forecast you
are predicting more rain to come over
the next few months why
yes so we're predicting that for the
period from november to january there's
going to be about a 30
chance of being wetter than average
whilst there's only a 10 chance of being
drier than average
and also
related to that where it's a 45 chance
of being milder than average so we're
talking about a milder wetter winter
um for the next three month period
we also outlined some of the the longer
term
uh forecasts and the impacts of climate
change how will they be felt
so what we expect for the uk is in the
future for us to have more frequent
milder wetter winters
and that is basically due to as the
climate warms the atmosphere is able to
hold more moisture and that leads to
increases in rainfall and alongside that
we expect to see decreases in snow and
also more frequent in extremes
and indeed some of these changes are
already being seen in the observational
record
um so for example five
of the um wettest years
of the five of the ten wettest years on
record have happened since 2000 so
that's for records going back to the
1860s so this is not something that we'd
expect to happen by chance so there is
evidence that the climate
is already changing here in the uk
what do we need to do then with that
information in order to prepare for
what's to come
so some of the information that we're
able to provide now is really bringing
the climate change projections right
down from the global scale to the local
scale and that is helping us to prepare
and make sure that the uk is resilient
to climate change
some of the results that we recently
have is looking for example changes in
very heavy rainfall amounts that could
be important for flash flooding so
exceeding 30 millimeters in an hour for
example could be two times more frequent
by the 20 70s if we follow a high
emission scenario
and this is information is really
important for example in terms of how we
design our infrastructure in our cities
and you know urban drainage systems are
not designed based on these sort of
rainfall rates they're based on
historical rainfall rates that are
traditionally lower so this information
is really needed to go through in terms
of how we design our infrastructure our
bridges
so that we're resilient to these changes
in the future
okay professor lizzie kenden thanks very
much indeed for talking to us here this
evening
now in today's other climate news 7
trent has brought forward plans to clean
up its rivers by 16 years after a major
investigation into sewage treatment was
launched the water company said it will
work with farmers and other key sectors
of the economy to improve the quality of
rivers the environment agency and
regulators are investigating more than 2
000 sewage works over concerns that raw
sewage is being illegally pumped into
rivers
oil company shell has announced plans to
build a biofuel plant in singapore to
help reduce its overall emissions the
plant will make hydrogen from cooking
oil and animal fats which can then be
used to produce diesel for trucks jet
fuels and chemicals shell has committed
to halving its co2 emissions by 2030
and a french paralympian has completed a
75-mile journey across the largest
freshwater lake in south america to
raise awareness of environmental
pollution theo kieran and his two
teammates swam from one side of late
titicata to the other taking it in turns
to rest on a raft made out of recycled
materials theo said he hopes to
encourage people to stop leaving tons of
rubbish by the lake each year
young people should receive more
education about climate change according
to the youngest sitting mp nadia whittem
has introduced a motion in the house of
commons today calling for climate change
and sustainability to be integrated
throughout the primary and secondary
curriculum i spoke to her earlier and i
started by asking her what the bill is
all about
our climate education bill comes from
young people school students themselves
and it's calling on the government to do
three broad things to integrate climate
education across the national curriculum
so currently it's only taught in
optional subjects like triple science
and geography but it needs to be taught
in every subject so i mean for example
teaching about sustainable food
production and diets and food technology
teaching plumbing students how to
install low carbon heating systems
it's also calling for
that to be met with adequate teacher
training so that teachers are able to
deliver this climate education and the
third thing is for the decarbonisation
of the of the education sector
much quicker than is currently happening
so that children are learning in
retrofitted buildings for example
in practical terms nowadays how do you
see this working are you talking about
specific time allocated in the
curriculum or thread running through all
lessons and what ages are you aiming at
this needs to run like a thread
throughout the curriculum in the same
way that the climate crisis impacts
every part of our lives we've seen from
the pandemic pandemics will become more
frequent as a result of
climate breakdown
and young people need to be part of the
solutions to that so for a lot of people
2050 might seem like a like a long time
away for our generation will still be in
our working lives for children who just
started school in september they won't
even be 35 by 2050
so we're calling for this to happen from
nursery through to primary through to
secondary and fe education
you mentioned student involvement in the
bill how has that worked
this piece of legislation has come from
young people themselves they wrote it
they were in parliament today while i
presented it to parliament and we hope
that with the cross-party support that
we have from mps of all parties
including the conservative party
including three select committee chairs
from the environmental audit education
and bay select committees that the
government will listen to us and act and
see this as a continuation of the pledge
that it made during cop on climate
education which was good but doesn't go
far enough
now dear whittem thanks very much indeed
for talking to us here on the daily
climate show
thank you
a man known as french spider-man has
climbed up a 39-storey skyscraper in
frankfurt to raise awareness of climate
change alain robert got his nickname
from climbing some of the world's
tallest buildings using just his bare
hands after his climb alan said he was
disappointed with the outcome of cop 26
in glasgow and urged world leaders to do
more to end
deforestation now do stay with us
because coming up after the break i'm
going to be joined by dame julia king a
member of the committee on climate
change and the guardian columnist george
monbiot we're going to be discussing if
the uk is prepared for more flooding and
whether using bioenergy is really better
for the planet than fossil fuels we'll
see in a couple of minutes
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show here on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with dame
julia king chair of the adaptation
subcommittee of the committee on climate
change and the guardian columnist george
monbiot the met office has warned that
this winter could be wetter than normal
with households urged to be prepared for
the risk of flooding climate change
means that the uk can expect heavier and
more intense rainfall that change will
continue over the next few decades
whether or not we're on a path to net
zero so is the uk prepared for a wetter
future well the environment agency says
1.5 million households are in flood risk
areas but haven't got any preparations
julia
that's not a good figure to be starting
with how do you improve and increase
resilience and preparedness
gosh um
but of course the environment agency has
a very good flood and coastal erosion
risk management strap fully funds them
to deliver it but of course they can't
protect us from everything and we need
to to do some things for ourselves so we
need to make sure that everybody is
signed up for flood warnings uh if they
live in an area that has that is um at
risk of flooding and we need to make
sure that people understand the kind of
precautions they should be taking so for
example uh if there's a
significant risk
then they should have a bag packed they
should make sure they have their
medicines ready they should make sure um
they can either move
precious things upstairs if necessary
they should be prepared to leave the
house taking their pets with them those
sorts of things but but in general we
need to be designing um both our homes
and our cities to uh to take into
account that there will be much more
water around so we need to take on board
what the chinese are doing which is
they're designing sponge cities cities
that are designed to absorb water
because as we heard earlier we're going
to be getting more periods of very
intense rainfall which can lead to
surface water flooding in our cities and
that's probably one of the types of
flooding we are least well prepared for
in the uk at the moment
george
whose responsibility is it to ensure
that we're prepared is it government or
is it individual responsibility
well there's not much that we can do by
ourselves we do need government to
intervene and we need it to be far more
effective than it has been so far i'm
slightly puzzled by the focus the
particular focus that a lot of people
have on
how we um absorb water in cities um as
julia has just been discussing because
of course cities are just a very small
part of a river's catchment and they're
at the bottom of the catchment we also
need to be intensely focused on what's
happening in the rest of that catchment
how well is the land absorbing and
holding back the rain how well are the
rivers slowing down the flow and if as
we've so often done we've canalized and
dredged the rivers we tend to speed up
the flow towards the cities until it
hits the nearest urban pinch point and
then bursts its bank what we need to do
is have rivers which hold back the water
for as long as possible so that they
allow the the flow to be attenuated to
be slowed down to come down instead of
in one great big pulse in a long slow
flow and that means allowing them once
more to meander to braid to form islands
and other obstructions that just slow
that water down similarly on the
hillsides let's get some trees back
let's get some um terracing in in in
important places let's do everything we
can to slow down the flow throughout the
entire catchment rather than sitting
there like rabbits in the headlight
waiting for this great wall of water to
come down and hit us and then wondering
what to do about it yeah sitting ducks i
guess julia are we getting the focus
wrong then when we when we prioritize
cities in our on our planning around
cities george arguing that we need to
take our focus further upstream
and no we need uh we need all of those
things
i was particularly talking about surface
water flooding which is the response to
periods of short short relatively short
periods of very intense rainfall so it's
not water in cities it's not water
coming from the rivers it's actually the
water coming from the sky and and
surface water flooding is something we
are less well prepared for in the uk
than we are for for coastal flooding and
river flooding but george is right of
course we should be using nature-based
solutions um to try and slow down the
the rate at which water comes into our
rivers when we have wet weather so those
sorts of things are very important as
well
george are there other areas i know
particularly you've talked about canada
british columbia where we should be
looking to
it's really shocking what's happening
there i mean it's a classic case of a
compound climate disaster so so as you
know there was this massive heat dome
over that region of western canada and
the western us um in the summer and
there were huge fires
those not only destroyed a lot of trees
they also helped to bake the soil all
that ensures that water runs off it more
and now we see this massive dump of
rainfall you know probably also
exacerbated by climate breakdown
and a lot of the communities in british
columbia are now flooded and in some
cases that flood water has frozen and is
likely to remain frozen for the whole
winter so what they're going to do
i mean it's just it's almost
unimaginable the situation that some
communities are in it's really really
horrible and i'm surprised there's so
little coverage of it in the news at the
moment
okay let's move on to our second topic
and this is bioenergy now bioenergy
refers to power that is generated from
organic matter known as biomass we heard
earlier in the program that shell is
planning a biofuel plant in singapore in
part to lower its emissions
and if we look at electricity being
generated in britain right now
we can see uh seven percent of that is
coming from biomass most of which is
from burning wood chips it is officially
designated as renewable because those
wood chips come from sustainable
plantations so how big a role should
biofuels play in the transition to a low
carbon economy uh george this is your
topic let's put that question to you
first i think the role should be about
zero it's an outrageous scam and um so
if you look at a situation like drax
they appear to have lower carbon
emissions because of a carbon accounting
convention which says that you don't
count carbon dioxide produced from
burning mashed up trees because one day
trees will grow back to replace the ones
you've mashed up well the one day is the
crucial issue it could take decades to
absorb that carbon which you've just
released and we don't have advocates we
need to front load our environmental
action they're doing exactly the
opposite and what we're seeing is a
massive new wave of forest destruction
caused by this supposedly green
technique of burning biomass and we're
seeing in some cases old growth forests
in europe and in north america being
failed to be turned into wood chip and
burnt is an absolute disgrace and it
needs to stop
julie biomass is classified as a
renewable fuel
is it clean or is it dirty as
george has described
um biomass can make a useful
contribution i think we know we have a
lot of commercial forestry in the uk
that forestry needs to be thinned there
are trees um which are not fit for um
producing uh you know for using in in
construction and things
those thinnings can be used usefully for
biomass and indeed if we can use
appropriately produced biomass and i
agree with george it's really critical
that we ensure it is appropriately
produced if we can use that in the
future with carbon capture and storage
that can play
a small but significant role in in
giving us negative emissions and getting
helping us get to net zero but i agree
with him it does have to be extremely
carefully managed uh george is it's
better than fossil fuels isn't it
no it isn't um forestry thinnings and
waste are always used as a trojan horse
to enable much bigger operations to go
ahead we're sold the idea on the basis
that it'll be waste products used it's
invariably we end up with
fresh material being used entire forest
areas being cut down and fed into these
burners it's really disgraceful and the
whole idea of bioenergy with carbon
capture and storage it is unicorn poo
it's a total pipe dream and honestly we
should just drop this nonsense and get
on with a genuinely clean energy
revolution based on renewables and i
think also fourth generation nuclear
ten seconds to get a final answer from
you then julia
um
well appropriately used sustainable
biomass forms part of the climate change
committee's pathway to net zero
thank you very much very succinct to
educate george monbiot thanks very much
indeed for joining us here on the daily
climate show this evening
that is everything from us for today
i'll be back tomorrow and on the show
i'll be joined by dr cc who from the
university of oxford's environmental
change institute and also richard black
senior associate at the energy and
climate intelligence unit
but do stay tuned because coming up next
on sky news tonight
new advice from the government in
northern ireland amid growing concern
over the rise in covid cases thanks very
much for watching us and we will see you
again here tomorrow on the daily climate
show
[Music]
you